I mean I think he was the one who would
have had the chance to meet Ann but I
don't think did you played her so what
was it like for you to play someone who
is easily that one of the most
recognizable figures of the 20th century
and you started your acting career
playing this person how did that affect
you moving forward with this I've never
acted I've never seen the Diary of Anne
Frank on Broadway I didn't my father had
been in the world war two and I knew
about atrocities and things that
happened in the war I was a little teeny
girl but I didn't know anything about it
and I was modeling and I and they kept
asking me a test for the movie and I
kept saying I'm not an actress thank you
I don't want to be an actress but I went
to Paris to model for the first time and
it was wonderful and I got there and I
was telling all my French friends these
people from Hollywood keep calling me
and asking me to test for this movie the
Diary of Anne Frank I had I don't know
anything about and the book the diary
and they said Oh Millie Millie that's a
very important book don't you know and I
said no they said George Stevens the
wonderful American director is directing
that I said George Stevens I was not a
fan of movies or movie stars but I had a
favorite book in high school called an
American tragedy by Theodore Dreiser and
he made a movie called a Place in the
Sun which for some reason was my
favorite movie and I heard yeah I
thought that man I know who he is he
directed my favorite movie maybe I ought
to meet him and and they flew me to
California to meet George Stevens and he
was he was had a heart
I read the diary on the plane going out
I'm sorry I'm sorry to say that's the
first time I read it it hit me in the
heart I thought oh this must be right
this something's right about this for me
and I just felt I was too old in a way
to play the part but I not too old but I
was older I wasn't 14 and I I just hit
me in the heart and I met George Stevens
and it was this lovely man
who treated me with respect I went he
said look let you know I went back to
New York to my modeling career as a
young girl and he and he said I'll let
you know and he called me up one day and
he said I'm gonna meet you at the Plaza
and I met him at the Plaza I had
corduroy jacket on and and slacks and no
pleated skirt a black pleated skirt a
green corduroy jacket no white blouse
and I went to the plaza the Tea Room and
he said we'd like you to play the part
but you must not tell anybody and I
didn't tell anybody Amy tell my family
it was just it was wonderful it did it
changed me it gave me a gift that's been
with me my whole life I'm 83 years old
I'm sorry Marian to tell you that my
friend never likes me to tell people my
age but it's been a gift and and I and
III I couldn't have asked more I've done
over 40 films nobody knows what they
were but they do know the Diary of Anne
Frank I've been I've been invited all
over the world I've invited everywhere
every synagogue every high school every
grammar school every in Holland and
every Israel to talk about the dire man
Frank can you imagine what's done to me
it's maybe maybe it's right I know